all right this is backstage I don't know  if we have got yet I haven't started  seating we've actually take a look at  this theater is pretty come on out here  well they have started seeing it but  we're going to do this anyway  go ahead and pan around nice let 1256  we have not left ase Tunsil the years  that I've been working here so that's a  great way to do it the nice place fun  room to work we're going to have a good  time than act I'm excited they got a  chubby now where's the emergency button  right over there now if I get that hand  on stage this will stop at all you just  push that in if I say cut more than five  times I'm out of here they're just boob  and not always that cut the power off it  also opens up a slide and I pull  straight out of the stage into the pits  of hell so it's a little scary you know  little scary